oh my God ew do you have bugs of the
flying Variety in your house fruit flies
if you happen to live in California
mosquitoes year round would you like to
get rid of them me too I saw these bug
catchers on the internet and I need to
try them because I'm over it so I just
got my Zevo flying insect trap you plug
it in it turns blue and you leave it so
they fly into the light and get stuck to
check it every 15 days as needed so we
will be back in 15 days to check to see
if either the kitchen or the downstairs
Zevo trap actually got any flies it has
officially been two weeks I'm going
downstairs
and we are gonna check what the Trap
looks like
I mean it works